comme chacun sait l'existence des mutins
a été découverte au moment des accords
de paris qui ont marqué la fin de la
guerre du vietnam
le 27 janvier 73 6 jours plus tard nous
avons tous pu voir l'un de ces mutants
erik lensherr attaqué notre président et
ses ministres dans les jardins de la
maison blanche
ils ne doivent leur vie qu'à la jeune
mutante qui s'est interposé
leicher s'est enfui et demeure le
fugitif le plus recherché au monde
quant à la jeune mutante elle a disparu
aussi mais non sans être devenu le
symbole d'une ère nouvelle
le visage d'un monde qui ne sera plus
jamais le du fait des clins d'oeil à
madonna alors certes préjugés ont la
suite on a jeté son client se trouve
dans la société tout entière
dites moi messieurs vous aviez quelque
chose à dire pour contribuer au court
peut-être je peux sortir s'il vous plaît
chez un problème aux yeux ça ne va pas
du tout va bien scott et d'ailleurs vous
en profiterez pour passer chez le
proviseur pour lui expliquer que vous
avez encore perturbé le cours
vous connaissez le chemin un peu fade
non attendez attendez
la gueule oui alors bien sûr vous aviez
dans les 3 7 ans à l'époque
saveurs cité cachée c'est pas la presse
m eur